welcome to a fresh take on the news
putting you at the center of the
national conversation about the issues
that matter to you most
tonight with russia on the war path
leaders around the world attempt to
figure out what if anything will stop mr
putin
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
tonight as ukraine comes under fire our
viewers panel from across the country
will share their stories they'll have
their say
and they'll hold our studio guest to
account
joining us this week
general sir richard sheriff
former deputy supreme allied commander
of nato
dr kojo koram author of uncommon wealth
britain and the aftermath of empire
the colonists broadcaster and former
labour special advisor aisha hazarika
and sir simon fraser policy analyst and
former permanent under secretary at the
foreign office
the question facing us all tonight
is britain still a global power
breaking news this morning is that it is
war
president putin's military operation in
ukraine is now well underway
whoever tries to hinder us should know
that russia's response will be immediate
[Music]
now we see him
for what he is a blood-stained aggressor
president putin of russia has unleashed
war in our european continent
nuclear forces on high alert we must
help that's what we've always done as a
country
i don't believe that the russian
dictator will ever subdue the national
feeling of the ukrainians
the air raid sirens are irregular now
it's scary stuff
someone praying for peace for this
country
let's start as always with our viewers
panel
i want to talk to lydia
a ukrainian viewer in the uk lydia
talk to us about your family's
experience
my my sister you know had to flick you
with your husband and son on wednesday
around five o'clock in the morning
they left just the buildings you know
the apartments and drop
in the car
without any needed stuff and they set
off to western
to west of ukraine where my parents live
but
they know
nowhere to hide from bombing you know
because
my parents live
from ivanovsk
in a few and few miles and the airport
has been bombed twice and they had been
shouting in basement
and all people kids
intense
uh anxiety we are in grief in sorrow all
around ukrainians in sorrow we can't
sleep we can't sing we win we won't
stop this war and ask you i am appealing
now to leaders so if you say uk european
unions help us because
i think this is not ukrainian's problem
this is human problems because putin is
hungry greedy president
i can't even call him leader because he
is evil devil
we need stop this because
to prevent
an even bigger war
lydia
i think everybody here hears you and i
should tell you they can hear you
there in ukraine too
move
and talk to another
person ukrainian background marina
ivanyak marina
hi i can't say good evening because it's
not good for me i have been protesting
every single day outside of downing
street where i lost my voice so i try to
speak as loud as i can
i have written the letter to the queen
with hope that she will and the country
the united kingdom will take the strong
action against russia
ukrainian military is strong and brave
but we need help from west we need to
stop bombs falling on our heads on heads
of the children they killing our
husbands sons women and child
ukraine signed the budapest memorandum
in 1994
and agreed to give up our nuclear weapon
in exchange that the united kingdom and
the west will guarantee the protection
and sovereignty to our country
first i want to say to sen say thanks to
the united kingdom to the boris johnson
to preeti patient who allowed our
asylum seeker to come to the country but
i want to ask the panel why is the
united kingdom is not taking real action
to stop the war to stop putin invasion
because when the ukraine will fall the
europe will be next the united kingdom
will be next um yeah thank you marina
thank you so much that was a very clear
question from marina
following russian's invasion of ukraine
why is the uk remaining
calm and not taking
real action
richard sheriff
what is the answer to that
well firstly um
thank you for
to lydia and marina
uh and what you say is is heart rending
beyond belief and i think we all
understand or try to understand
the grief and the pain that you and your
countrymen and women are going through
this is like a nightmare
which we're living through
um
to the question why
what is the united kingdom doing and why
can't it do more
i think it would be fair to say that the
united kingdom
has not been
sitting on its hands
clearly
i can completely understand why you feel
that it is not enough
uh but for some 20 years the united
kingdom has been
training and supporting and equipping
the ukrainian armed forces
the united kingdom has sent i think
quite a significant amount of
arms and ammunition and equipment to
ukraine in in recent in recent weeks
um
and
the united kingdom i'm sure will do what
it can to support indirectly
but then you have come to the real
question
why cannot it support ukraine directly i
guess what you're really saying is why
is the united kingdom not putting
soldiers on the ground in ukraine
richard sherida i won't i want to come
to that in a moment but
uh could we do more simon fraser you
when you were at foreign office probably
would have been in
all of those meetings the cobra meetings
and all the rest of it deciding
what do we do
what would you be advising yeah how
would you answer that i would have been
those meetings but how i answer that um
is to say look um it goes that goes
partly to the whole question that we're
discussing is the uk still a global
power we have power but we don't have
the capacity on our own as a country i
think to take on russia military or to
put troops for example on the ground in
ukraine
and so we have to work with other
countries
and i would certainly have been saying
we need the strongest possible alignment
with america with other western
democracies the european union and nato
allies to take action and although we
don't actually have a commitment to
ukraine as a nato ally and that is
something we could debate as to whether
we should actually have that commitment
but what we have seen is a pretty robust
reaction by those democracies in a
united way which has certainly taken
putin by surprise now it doesn't solve
the problem for those people who are
suffering on the ground in ukraine at
the moment but i think at least we could
say that the reaction has been in many
ways stronger than i expected and that
is at least
you know a relatively good point i think
for us to take all right
all right let let's come in a way to the
point that richard sheriff's started to
address i'm going to talk to steve
diasha
in manchester who i think has a point
for our panel steve
yeah uh firstly i think on our phones so
we've lived here and with all the people
of ukraine and ukraine itself and that
we do sound firmly behind you
being this notion of myself
um this makes my blood boil just knowing
how yet again we throw sanctions
and putin
and he just laughs us in our faces
because it's just words words words i
need laughs and it means i'll ensue him
we cut off his assets
we cut off the swift banking systems
which putin doesn't care about because
of we know he's using the cryptocurrency
you know you know it's that is one of
those things what is a possibility
what's not being thought about yet
we want to put boots on the ground we
want to send people into ukraine but
until ukraine becomes a member of nato
as a country as a nation there's not a
lot we cannot do and and it's horrible
because believe you me i would put on my
boots tomorrow
as soon as ukraine became a member of
nato and i will be standing side by side
on the ground helping ukraine and its
people claim back the country so we need
to let ukraine become a member of nato
as soon as possible thank you steve
marina how do you respond to what steve
dash has just said
about putting boots on the ground in
ukraine
we need the help of every single person
so if someone can come and help us
we
we're just waiting for that help so
everyone who can come please come and
support us in every step humanitarian
help if you can come and physically
protect us come and protect us please
thank you marina aisha hazurika
is that part of the answer here well i
think a lot of people will have found it
quite extraordinary that our foreign
secretary
indicated that she would support
british citizens that wanted to to take
up that call to arms the president
zelensky set up setting up this
international legion she said she would
support people
yet we will not put british boots on the
ground now we all understand the reasons
that ukraine is not a member of nato and
we're very mindful that you know for
nato
equipment and nato soldiers etc to start
attacking russia that takes it into
another dimension however
if
there is
if president putin and let's be honest
he has underperformed so far he's been
humiliated by the ukrainians resistance
and their spirit and their defiance
if he moves into using chemical weapons
or using weapons of mass destruction
nato has got to revisit the question
there may be the rules about nato but
there's a moral question that nato and
the west will have to answer richard
sheriff
i think we need to be clear
if britain
and other nato countries
got involved
directly in fighting in ukraine
that is the start of the third world war
no question about it and similarly if
any attempt to impose a no-fly zone
would guarantee the start of the third
world war
it is a brutal fact of life that ukraine
is not a member of nato
and therefore is not covered by the
guarantee of collective defense that
says an attack on one is an attack on
all
so
the very the most the most appropriate
the very best that nato can do now is to
stop this
uh
any form of of of uh
expansion of the war
by defending nato territory
demonstrating that it is prepared
to fight to the teeth to protect nato
territory but also
to continue to support ukraine
indirectly with weapons with equipment
potentially and other capabilities as
well
and also
to start helping the ukrainians prepare
to fight underground if it comes to that
coach corum is that enough
well i think first of all thank you to
marina and lydia for their
heart-wrenching testimony and full
solidarity goes to the ukrainian people
for the horrors that we've witnessed
them go through over the past week but i
think that the question of what that
solidarity looks like
relies on our idea of what is the most
useful thing britain can do to help the
people of ukraine what's the most useful
thing that britain can do to weaken
vladimir putin and the horrors that
we've seen in the ukraine over the past
week have prompted a long overdue
conversation
in the uk about why the kleptocrats that
have propped up pluton's regime have
used london as their base of operation
if we're dealing with the military
question here should we
be in a position to put our soldiers
into that theater
i think a unilateral
entrance into war with putin is not
something that would be an option we
need to think about how humanitarian
intervention has worked in the past and
we need to think is there non-military
tactics that could actually be more
harmful to putin than boots on the
ground and i think that that financial
weakening of him is part of that all
right let me go back to our viewers
panel and i'd like to talk to emmanuel
ojingwa
emmanuel
what is your view about what we could do
um good evening travel
and i think that
we knew that this was going to happen
we had the intel
um
we knew months ago that the war was
going to happen so it didn't take us by
surprise
what is unfolding at the moment is not a
surprise to us
we knew that we needed to hit putin with
sanctions enough sanctions to make
things
more difficult for him so my question to
the panel is
have we really done enough why didn't we
use the sanctions that are on at the
moment to hit him hard enough to make
sure that we could have prevented what
was going on now thank you emmanuel
simon fraser mr putin annexed crimea in
2014 he's never made much secret of his
view
that he wanted to reconstruct
either the russian or the soviet empire
whatever he wants to call it we could
have seen this coming well we could i've
seen it coming i suppose and we could
have taken it more seriously i think it
i wouldn't defend the fact that you know
with hindsight uh maybe we certainly
misread him i think i mean it's a very
good question that's been raised as
whether we could have done more sooner
to deter this action
um it's not true that we knew this was
going to happen months ago i mean there
were indications it might happen i think
that we didn't know it was going to
happen until relatively recently again
maybe that was a misreading of putin and
you know one of the great things in
diplomacy in international relations is
you really have to understand where your
adversary is coming from sometimes you
make the mistake of thinking that
everybody thinks the same they think
about the world in the way that we think
about it and that can be a mistake so we
could perhaps have done more to deter
this impose the sanctions earlier we
were late to do what we've done i accept
that charge actually but on the on the
other hand we have moved very fast when
we've woken up we may have woken up too
too late but we have woken up and if you
look at what for example the european
union and germany and others have now
done
it's pretty remarkable too late maybe
but let's hope that it's not too late to
actually influence putin in the long run
and damage him in the way that's been
described so that we can deter him from
further violent action okay well you
mentioned the other european powers so
coming up our viewers and studio
panelists will be discussing if there
are any leaders strong enough to stand
up to russia the european union will
finance the purchase and delivery of
weapons
we will invest more than 2 of our gdp in
defence every year from now on putin
chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences this hideous and barbaric
venture of vladimir putin must end
in failure
leaders of the free world if you won't
help us today tomorrow war will be
knocking on your door
is britain still a global power
it's not just the uk which has responded
to the attack on ukraine countries
around the world have condemned
president putin's actions and imposed
retaliatory measures in response
but is the russian leader taking any
notice
let's start things off with a question
from our viewers panel and i want to
talk to
joni cunningham joni you're in bristol
please talk to us
hi there um i've got a quick question um
is president putin taken advantage of a
lack of leadership in european countries
there seems to be a vacuum of power um
i'm wondering whether we've perhaps kind
of sleep walking into this a little bit
and your view about this is
what's your own answer to your question
uh yeah i do think there's been a vacuum
of leadership i feel like um you know
maybe not currently but previous leaders
i think we've been sleepwalking a little
bit um
i think it's been on the agenda i'm just
wondering um what the panel spots are in
that thank you very much joni well look
jony's question is this
is president putin taking advantage of a
lack of leadership in european countries
simon fraser well i think one of the
reasons why he chose to act now
is because it was opportunistic he saw
that this was a moment of maximum
weakness in the west the americans are
weakened after afghanistan and they're
very divided at home
britain i mean we have domestic
political problems here and of course
after can you imagine what you're
talking about and after brexit as well i
think our position is unclear on a
number of these things and in europe uh
we've had a change of government and
coalition in germany president macron is
you know up for re-election so for a
number of reasons there's been a lot
going on and yes i think it's fair to
say there was unclarity and a lack of
focus and a lack of leadership but i'll
make the point again that
once he's taken this action i've been
positively surprised by the way that the
european countries both at national
level and collectively through the eu
and in nato have actually responded and
and indeed the european commission a
much blind organization in this country
uh under uh uh president uh
the president of the commission ursula
vunderlane has actually made some really
dramatic moves in terms of announcing
sanctions and extending for example the
funding of uh
military equipment to ukraine in quite a
significant way so there has been a lack
of leadership but it seems to have come
together recently cody quorum
um so i think the points that simon
makes are really insightful and we need
to recognize that this points to the
kind of a logic of putin's plan even on
its own basis that it resulted in a
unification of nato and the unification
of the west in a way that hadn't
happened for a generation i think that
the economic sanctions are welcome but i
think they can go much further i think
that we need to remember that russia
holds about half of its wealth offshore
it's an incredible level of financial
exposure for a great power one that
might be unprecedented in history and
this could be an opportunity to really
weaken the financial support that keeps
putin in power and i think that's the
next step that needs to be pushed
forward all right we'll come back to
that
let's go back to our the war let's go to
the viewers panel natasha dillon
um
do you think that we have
the leadership that can really challenge
putin
he's a tough guy
sorry putin is a playground bully he's
consumed by his lust for power and his
desire to keep the legacy of reuniting
the ussr
his words and actions have become
increasingly deranged and the west has
been following its usual bureaucratic
procedures in an orderly fashion
we're facing an unhinged despot with his
finger on the button and we cannot wait
for sanctions to take effect we're at a
critical point in our history and if
we're too slow to act decisively this
war will have far-reaching consequences
for the entire world
i think that the only leadership
currently that could stand up to putin
is nato and i don't see why we can't
allow nato some
allow ukraine some emergency membership
to nato because if we don't stand up to
putin now he will not stop at ukraine
thank you
tasha uh
richard sheares
this would have fallen into your lap as
the deputy supreme commander in nato i
mean to the question of is there the
leadership to stand up to this man well
the old line cometh
cometh the r cometh a man or woman and
we must hope that cometh the man or
woman i can tell you somewhere that
cometh the man is evident and that is in
ukraine with president zielinski he has
really stepped up to the mask mark and i
think we have to admire
his courage and his charisma
i think it's too early frankly uh to the
previous question
uh from the lady from bristol about has
has lack of leadership in a sense led to
where we are now the answer is
categorically yes in the west i'm afraid
so now it's up to we know this is a come
as you are party uh we've got a deal
we've got to do this with the leaders
we've got so we've got to hope they step
up to the mark
thank you you're talking johnson macron
uh
draghi uh now schultz you're saying
these guys don't i have what it takes
i'm saying
we better hope they do
the jury is out
but to the point about nato
nato
we need to be clear about this
if nato is to get involved on the ground
in ukraine
nato is going to have to fight the third
world war
from a standing start
what have we seen thus far
nato has started the process of re uh
reinforcing the uh the eastern flank
with the nato response force
it's a start
but that does not yet constitute a
genuine war fighting capability and it
will take some time to generate that
because the reality is
i'm afraid that we have seen
a decade and a half if not longer of
cumulative disarmament in europe
of depending on america to
under underpin european defense
and now i'm afraid the chickens are
coming home to roost so what
it's not too late
we can do something about it but i'll
let you ask somebody else another
question aisha hazurika you
said uh a moment ago we should put boots
on the ground
general richard's saying that world war
iii right there
i'm not
advocating that now i'm saying if
there are practices of genocide or
weapons of mass destruction or chemical
weapons being used but to the question i
think we have to be honest that leaders
in europe were completely unprepared for
this on a political level on an economic
level on a military level on an
emotional level and a cultural level and
psychological level i think we have all
been very very naive about president
putin and all the signs have been there
and that's because a lot of countries
have been too inward-looking you know we
in britain have had this huge drama
happening over brexit and internal
things and what is it that we have
learned from this episode there is
strength in unity and i really hope that
european leaders step up and i think
we're seeing that but there is one other
leader who could be germane in this and
that is president xi of china because if
we are closing off western markets and
reliance to russia then china is the
next go-to we know that xi and putin
have a close relationship china
abstained at a big security council vote
president xi could be key in what
happens next big point and i definitely
want to come back to that a little later
but let's just stick with the european
uh territory for a moment and i want to
talk to malcolm severin
i suppose my question is would putin
have risked this if trump was still
president
he and other would-be despots knew that
trump himself was mad enough to launch
his missile rather than just words
um what we face next china invading
taiwan north korea invading south korea
the point has been made and i totally
agree we've allowed the west to be seen
as very weak and despots do not respond
well they do respond to weakness with
aggressive action
well there's a
i can say a couple of thumbs up to that
simon
fraser
what's your view about that well if
we've been better off with trump correct
well i mean interesting enough of course
trump uh came out and said that he's
that putin's move have been very savvy
uh taking over some some some nice
territory in ukraine so i don't think we
can take trump too seriously i mean
actually trump is largely responsible
for the disunity of the west which we've
been talking about he undermined nato he
was aggressive and hostile towards
nato partners he created a lot of
uncertainty in the west so i don't think
he's the answer i do agree however with
what what has been said that what we
really need is unity amongst the western
powers and western countries using the
institutions we have the european union
nato and others and we're supposed to be
talking about the uk so let's just make
the point i don't think the uk's record
over the last few years in terms of
being active in promoting unity in
europe is a very impressive one and i
hope we will learn a lesson from this
that we need to work with other
democracies in europe and not antagonize
them all right thank you very much
is britain still a global power
before we come back to our viewers panel
we're joined from kiev by ivana klimpos
former vice prime minister of ukraine
and current chair of the parliamentary
committee on the integration of ukraine
to the eu good evening
ivana
thank you for having me if it's any good
because it's not good here in ukraine
well i was going to ask you to just
start by telling us
what what is the mood tonight in kiev
what are you hearing what are you seeing
the mood is
pretty tough because we've had uh some
very serious uh
uh rockets being just
sent over the city and um and we had
several major blasts
around the city and also what we are
seeing right now is that um russia you
were just discussing in your program
about the nuclear threat and i'm just
going to tell you that
russian airplanes
after they russians have
occupied territory where the chernobyl
nuclear power station is
they right now are flying over it and
sitting there are shooting directly at
cave and we cannot respond because we
we are um worried that this way we will
be shooting at nuclear power station so
um you might underestimate
the nuclear threat is much much closer
um even from that fact that uh putin has
announced that he is um going to put his
nuclear deterrence on alert
is it
is it your concern
that
there may be in the midst of all of this
inadvertently without anybody meaning
for it to happen
a nuclear accident
absolutely unfortunately
uh putin and
his army is are targeting
not only the critical infrastructure
objects and
but among them
um already several
electric power stations and
somewhere there we do have atomic power
stations across the country
so they might hit in into one of those
uh moreover as i mentioned chernobyl is
under their control at this particular
moment and we are not receiving and
magate is not receiving any information
on what the radiation uh situation uh is
there in this particular moment we were
in as you heard discussing uh the last
part the question of
the european action european support
do you think you could have had more
help faster from the eu from britain and
from the united states
absolutely i think if uh
if we wouldn't have uh postponed the
actions that we were asking for for
eight years uh since the war
offers administration has started
against ukraine in the east of ukraine
and in the uh with the ill
legal totally um
annexation of crimea if at that point
the sanctions were not pitiful that the
west has taken uh we
and if you were more um engaging in
helping us to arm ourselves and to
ensure that we are we have a bigger
defense capacity to
um to withheld
possible
possible uh developments we would have
been much better off can i just ask you
you of course are
in charge of this or just committee
which is about uh uk ukraine's
relationship with the eu
would it have made a difference do you
think if you had been
in the eu
and
where is this where is the status of
your application now
you know just today there was a
common political move from actually all
the political parties besides one which
is a criminal party in ukraine uh where
political our political leaders have
taken the the
letter to the european parliament asking
uh to grant candidate status and quick
um quick lane first lane for ukrainian
eu membership and also president zineski
has signed the letter uh to the
european union asking for membership uh
that's where we are obviously there is
no official response at this particular
moment
ivana uh klimpush
thank you so much for being with us this
evening thank you and uh
stay
safe here
thank you
let's go back to the wall and talk to
felix
[ __ ]
since brexit the uk has undoubtedly lost
the ability to be part of a large
collective voice resulting in delays to
important announcements such as the
helping of ukrainian refugees however
the uk is still the world's largest
leading soft power according to the
institute for government it's still a
member of nato the g7 and a permanent
member of the u.n security council his
capital london is the financial capital
of the world beating new york and paris
and the uk has been a leading voice
against putin's vision of ukraine
so my question to the panel did brexit
reduce the uk's influence on the world
stage
thank you felix there's a very direct
question panel the question there from
felix is has brexit reduced the uk's
influence on the world stage kojo korum
well i think it's difficult to argue
against the idea that brexit both as a
legal process and as a national debate
contributed to this atmosphere of
isolationism and
protectionism that we see all across the
world in fairness to brexit and to the
interest of not reopening that whole
conversation i think it's important to
recognize that it was part of a global
trend towards increasing isolationism we
see that in trump we see that all across
the globe but i think we need to
recognize that this disinvestment from
ideas of multilateralism from an
international rules-based order has
eroded the ability to limit autocrats
like putin taking the actions they've
done over the past week i think there's
been a lot of conversation over the
course of this panel about the
importance of unity in europe we think
about the eu and think about nato but i
also think it's important to recognize
that the foundational institution of an
international rules-based order is the
united nations and the united nations is
something that has been weakened um
and i think the uk has a role in being
able to put that back together like
felix mentioned it's still a member of
the security council and needs to try
and reinforce that institution richard
sheriff did brexit make any difference
well from from my perspective as an
ex-professional soldier and part of nato
uh but also um as uh
because of the role i played i was also
an eu command operation commander as
well and that allowed uk to have a foot
in both camps and to be able to bring
the capabilities of nato to bear to
support the european union
i'm afraid it did now i'm very aware of
course
the majority voted for it so we have to
get on with it
but i fear that the sort of squabbling
divisions
isolationism that that koja touched on
um has impacted on us i want to talk to
judith randall who i know um
had rather strong views on the issue of
brexit uh
where are you on this now judith
um
i still have strong views
i also would like to say that my heart
goes out to the people of ukraine
they are innocent victims whose country
is under attack without provocation
and i have no words for putin but i do
want to say that i personally voted to
lead the eu at the time none of us knew
what we were actually voting for and the
impact of leaving the eu has been much
bigger than we thought
we voted in effect
for
a divided europe and putin has taken
full advantage
thank you judith well aisha i think
that's a view that you're going to be
pretty sympathetic to but let me just at
least put
uh what go on prime minister might say
if he's here we now have the freedom to
act and by the way
we were first into the ring
on uh making the case
for taking russia out of the swift
uh banking system and that's part of our
independence
i really push back against that trevor
good try uh and you know
god loves a trio but let's be honest
right part of the bigger narrative about
this is upholding international law
through brexit through this torture
situation with northern ireland we our
own government has been pulled up by
saying we will break international law
in a limited and specific way so brexit
has of course weakened us we've all had
a discussion about the power of unity
yet we have decided to go it alone but
and i do want to give an objective
balance view on this i don't think it
has meant that we haven't had a really
important role to play in this conflict
i do think boris johnson has made the
right noises but there's one area where
boris johnson could show to remainers
like me that britain's place in the
world will not be diminished and that is
by having a much more open-hearted
generous program for refugees we should
be opening britain up the same way that
the eu has opened itself up that is one
way for boris johnson pretty patel liz
trust to send a signal to everyone in
britain and everybody across the world
that britain is a global player and that
we are huma um humane and compassionate
well thank you for that because actually
that's exactly where we're going as
fighting continues in ukraine we'll ask
what the crisis could mean for the uk
and what more as a country we could do
to help those affected
these coaches are full of women and
children and pensioners who are fleeing
their country
an additional 100 000 ukrainians will be
able to seek sanctuary in the uk
we walk about 20 kilometers
and we are exhausted i want to survive
because i have a family in europe
the innocence of youth displaced by the
horror of war
the scenes of thousands of people
fleeing the conflict in ukraine have
been some of the most powerful of recent
days and the uk government has come
under significant pressure to commit to
helping those displaced by the fighting
judy faye you're in tewksbury we are
dealing with the here and now we're
dealing with um a socio-economic war
we're dealing with a um an arms war
and we're also potentially dealing with
the cyber war as well
but what the discussion has been leading
up to is what is
vladimir putin's end game
does he will he be happy with the
restoration of the ussr or does he want
more does he actually want an alliance
with china for example to create a
superpower
which will really really change the
balance of power on in the world
so that's my question how prepared are
we as a country to deal with the
consequences of whatever his endgame is
julie thank you so much for that
question
how prepared is britain to deal with the
consequences of the attack on ukraine
aisha hazarika
i don't think we are psychologically
prepared as a country i think we're a
sort of weak into to this crisis
um we're all getting our heads around it
we all have huge empathy and solidarity
with what's happening in ukraine i think
people are frightened here as well
particularly with the talk of nuclear
weapons being used but we have to think
about the practical consequences number
one your contributors write a new world
order we have to think about that number
two what we do about refugees i think we
have to open ourselves up but that will
take money it will take planning it
means the whole of the uk needs to play
its part working with councils but the
third thing we need to think about is
that this conflict has collided with uh
post-brexit post-pandemic and of course
an energy crisis and an existing cost of
living crisis there is going to be an
economic hit to the citizens of this
country as well uh we could see energy
bills going up to 3 000 pounds a year i
think our politicians do need to prepare
the citizens of this country for what is
coming down the track simon fraser
well i think julie makes a very good
point i mean we've grown too comfortable
since the end of the cold war uh we've
thought that this would carry on and
we've you know that everything would be
fine and it's not we now have war in
europe we have a challenge to the whole
international system and we need what we
need to do is realize that if we believe
in our societies and the values of our
societies which i think we do we've got
to be prepared to stand up for them and
that's the lesson that i think we're
drawing out of this conversation we've
got to be united clear and we've got to
have will
to not only react to what putin does but
to decide what we want and impose it and
just picking up on the china point very
briefly if i may i think there is a risk
that the china chinese and the russians
may make common cause but i wouldn't
exaggerate it for the time being i think
the chinese if you look at their
behavior so far they're being cautious
they're being relatively neutral they
abstained in the united security united
nations security council vote uh they
don't really want to get dragged into
putin's war
so let's not you know if we are careful
in our diplomacy and if we work
carefully with china whilst not
underestimating the risk from them uh
it's not necessarily that they will join
up with russia all right let's talk
to um actually now quite an old friend
of the program patrice wellesley cold
and you are
have been an immigration judge patrice
what do you make of this point about
migration
good evening trevor thank you yes well
so far over 500 000 have fled ukraine
according to the unhcr
fearing for their lives whom we will
have to welcome here in the uk
um what is really important is that we
talk about these people not as a wave of
migrants but as asylum seekers in fear
of their lives
the uk needs to do the very best it can
to support them
last night the prime minister said going
to nearby countries like poland
and hungary and they've set up
reception centers for them so not all of
them will come here
and many will come to england if they
have um family here there's a family
reunion policy so i i think we need to
open our arms it's a humanitarian crisis
thank you patrice kojo i think that the
importance of a generous and
well-resourced well-funded refugee
policy that jimmy and aisha mentioned is
really central and it's something that
we're seeing across europe and it's
something that needs to be replicated
here in the uk but i do want to stress
that i think that
in contrast to these other european
countries there is something else that
the uk can do to weaken putin that they
are not able to do because of the
relationship between the wealth of putin
and the city of london as well as
britain's overseas territories in the
cayman islands and the british virgin
islands britain has the ability to
strike at the oligarch wealth that
supports putin this is another ambitious
aggressive move that the government
should be making as well as supporting
refugees okay thank you
unfortunately that's all we have time
for this evening just remained for me to
thank our panelists
simon fraser aisha hazurika richard
sheriff
kojo korum
that you at home who are always at
centre of this conversation
if you'd like to be part of the program
next time get in touch by emailing the
great debate at sky dot uk
for now i want to thank everybody who's
been on the viewers panel
difficult subject but you guys were
as great as ever thank you so much
and of course you're home keep talking
and we'll see you again at the same time
next week for the great debate